spider-man's got a lot on his plate
bad guys at every corner relationships
to work on a real job he may be swamped
sometimes but that doesn't mean you have
to be while playing spider-man that's
why we've come up with seven tips that
will help you get started with your web
slinging career okay first things first
every crime fighter needs a map right so
the faster you can repair these Oscorp
radio towers the faster you can get out
- punching bad guys otherwise you're
going to be staring out a completely
fuzz down map for a decent chunk of the
game an effective Spider Man needs to
have full awareness of their environment
so make repairing the towers the first
thing you do while combat skills and
defensive maneuvers are essential
aspects to your repertoire there really
isn't anything more essential to the
spider-man experience trademark then web
slinging so if you're into that kind of
thing I would recommend diving straight
into that particular skill tree first
you'll learn some useful abilities to
help you traverse the city better and
make the opening hours of the game much
more invigorating aim to get the point
launched quick recovery and charge jump
as soon as possible and you'll be flying
through the city in record time
[Music]
as Uncle Ben once said with new suits
comes new suit powers or something like
that
I don't know my memories kind of hazy
but by combining suit powers with your
gadgets along with the three suit mod
slots you'll be able to create some
spectacular combos for example if you're
fighting a bunch of goons you could
shoot a loaded up web bomb then let out
an ear-splitting solo with a rock out
power to send them all flying maybe
you'll want to take to the skies and
pair the suspension matrix with low
gravity for some serious hang time or
you could just let your robots do the
dirty work for you use a spider drone
and spider bro for a tag-team takedown
spider-man's combat is all about
creatively combining the effects of your
gadgets suit powers and suit mods
together for disastrous results be a
responsible crime fighter and take time
to mix and match and see what works best
that's how Uncle Ben would want it the
OLM down do you as much fun as it is to
swing through the city there are still a
lot of things to see on the streets of
New York so it takes some time out of
your friendly neighborhood spider-man II
to appreciate the details on the ground
floor give people high-fives
eavesdrop on the chatter check out the
iconic New York City landmarks some good
Samaritans will even give you tips on
crimes nearby Spidey's on the case
[Music]
later on the game you'll come across
stations that allow you to take on
challenges they might be combat or
stealth focused or might have you
chasing a drone across the city rooftops
got it make sure not to skip these
though as they'll reward you with up to
six very valuable challenge tokens that
you'll need later on to upgrade your
gadgets and suit powers
as any good piece of Marvel
Entertainment should be spider-man is
loaded with Easter eggs and references
to the characters extensive lore hey my
Marquand web-shooters for example there
are several landmarks that are direct
nods to famous Marvel characters and
organizations when you're not out
fighting crime be sure to set some time
aside so search for these references it
may not benefit your progression
directly but it's worth doing if only to
be in awe of all the little details
packed into the world if you're a
completionist and can't possibly imagine
yourself not getting all of spider-man's
spiffy new suits then you're gonna want
to listen up in order to unlock the
final outfit you'll need to complete
each of an Hatton's 9 districts that
means finishing every single side quest
completing all the activities and
finding every single collectible that's
why I cannot emphasize this enough do
not skip the crime activities if you see
a red exclamation icon pop up in your
mini-map make that your top priority
you're gonna want to complete as many as
you can over the course of the main
story otherwise you're gonna be spending
a whole lot of time wandering the
streets searching for thugs to beat up
see a crime happening
take them down that's the Spidey way
so those were seven tips that will help
you get started being a better
spider-man than I ever was when I
started the game if you have any more
suggestions for things people should
know before starting make sure leave in
the comments below and check back on
gamespot comm for much much more
spider-man coverage thanks for watching
[Music]